i'm not just talking about the left in
liberals let's let's not forget let's
not have a short memory yeah we know
when this pandemic hit you actually
tried to make me uh work out things with
sam harris i mean we had conservatives
people that were in the middle that were
saying no lockdowns now at least for now
at least for a couple of weeks yeah and
i was always like hell no hell no i know
what this is
it's paralyzing fear you're showing us
uniquely even the death count i mean how
bizarre for a news organization to say
stay at home and then every time
somebody dies just add a number on the
screen i mean that's literally a game of
psychological fear right and i knew it
was coming around the corner um and it
shocked me how much people left and
right were willing to give up their
freedom because they had a little bit of
fear right it shocked me i wasn't one of
them and i know that a lot of people
have come around on the conservative
side and said no more but how do we get
people to understand that we can't get
to the point where you say no more it
has to be never right in the beginning
when you're fearing fearful you can't
say well i was okay with the lockdowns
for two weeks but you know what one year
is a little too long for me right you've
already lost
all right we are on location on the set
of candice and i'm with candace owens on
your set lady not too shabby come a long
way you have come a long way you being
one of my first interviews on your set
so there we go that's right uh everyone
knows the story between us that knows
our history but real quick to recap in
one minute when i brought you on to my
show originally we were doing youtube
week we were just trying to find like
anyone on youtube doing anything
interesting we found this girl red pill
black i did not know your name until we
sat down in those chairs a minute before
we started
and now you've basically like lit the
world on fire yeah yeah it's crazy to
think back like so much i didn't even
know then like i
obviously was not looking to get into
politics and if i look back on the
interview i feel
so young you know like so not really
knowing what i was stumbling upon but
knowing i kind of had this feeling that
something was really wrong and i had
been lied to
um and wow what a role when it's been
over the last four years so out of all
the people that i've interviewed and
we've talked about this many times
privately but out of all the people that
i interviewed we finished that first
interview i turned to david i was like
that girl is going to be a superstar it
was just so obvious but did you have
this plan at all like i know you were
kind of curious and you were figuring it
out and there were one or two things
that i asked you about politics that you
were kind of like i don't know yet i
don't want to comment on that yet which
i thought was pretty impressive actually
but you have just like marched forward
the machine has tried to destroy you how
many times now
you keep it keep a running count
definitely have lost count and
you know i think again kind of hinting
at the naivety of that first interview
which is really beautiful to watch is
that i just never could have imagined
that people would try to destroy me i
never would have imagined even that i
wasn't allowed to not have an opinion on
some things that i wasn't allowed to
grow as a person and say i'm still
learning because i was still learning i
didn't i had ideas and feelings about
things but i didn't really have the
facts on my side and i had no idea when
you're in politics it's just not they're
just looking to expose you and she's a
fake she's a fraud oh look she doesn't
know this she's stupid so i had to grow
up pretty quick you know and and really
kind of sharpen my figurative sword and
really get ready and do a lot of
studying um but yeah i i could have
never imagined i had no plan i was just
saying what i thought to be real and
what i thought to be true yeah and i
know that you're not just saying it
because every time i've been with you
when we've done road gigs together or
whatever like you've got 10 books with
you we had dinner at your house last
night you're you're working on farming
now like you're always just trying to
learn more and more and i will be
welcomed at your off location site right
when the group goes down and everything
yeah when the grid goes down yeah i i
actually as you just hinted on like i'm
kind of going through this thing now
where i realized that you know we are
all dependents and we are all on welfare
if we don't know how to grow our own
food and support ourselves and i think
that that really speaks to
the drama of this administration
of realizing that i know a lot of
americans empathize with the idea that
we feel like we're losing our country
and that we really have communists in
the white house um and you know we are
we are watching all of americans be
depressed and in that vein i said to
myself you know if this really does hit
right if we are suddenly living in a
communist country in three years four
years however you want to call it
can i can i spend for myself yeah two
months right uh can i fend for myself
can i grow my own food what do i know
about living off of the land um so that
is something yeah that i'm just now
learning now and what better place to do
it than in tennessee right i mean
everybody's you know farming hunting uh
so yeah that's kind of another thing
that i'm exploring now can you believe
that you live in tennessee i mean i said
to you guys last night like you so are
obviously in the right place so happy in
the house is great and little george is
great like you've just embraced it but
do you kind of sit back and go wow i
ended up in tennessee five years ago
little youtuber from philly like and
here i am now and on your own set with
your own crew and the whole thing
married to an englishman in tennessee if
you had said to me that first day that
we sat down like here's here's what's
gonna happen you're gonna end up living
in nashville tennessee uh and you're
gonna be married to an englishman that
you have gotten to engage to after two
weeks yeah of knowing each other um i
would have thought you were nuts and my
life has been pretty nuts and pretty
unpredictable um you know tennessee in
my heart i think i maybe thought i would
end up in texas i love texas i love the
texans and obviously opportunity came
knocking in tennessee and now that i'm
here i could never imagine living
anywhere else like this is fully where
we want to raise our family we think it
is the greatest state we love the people
there really is something about the
tennesseans yeah do you think america is
just this is how it's going to be like
you're just going to have to move to
places that are more in line with your
values or is there a point of someone
staying in say california or new york
and fighting like do you think that that
point have we crossed that already i do
not think that there will ever be a
clean election in california i think
that gavin newsom has made sure that
that can't happen um to say you know
mail-in ballots into perpetuity if
forget it no um new york city i i don't
have much hope for either um i can't
imagine i mean when i when i go to new
york city it's like already stepping
into a communist country
where the people are okay with their
oppressions i mean the idea of having to
show papers every time you walk into a
restaurant or have a transaction like
that's that's actually not america so i
would almost say that that's not a
future prediction that's a present one
like new york and california um and i
should say more los angeles i shouldn't
you know say the whole state of
california but those are not american
american cities what has that told you
about or what have you learned about
just humans the way a certain set of
people just want more that's what i feel
like in los angeles when i walk around
i'm like man you guys like this and
you're begging for more control that's
been a very weird thing to kind of
realize yeah what it says to me is that
fear is one hell of a currency um and i
have been hitting on this on my own show
making people aware of the fact that the
second somebody can identify what it is
that you are fearful over they can exert
control over you i don't think that we
have ever seen that um displayed more
than in the cobin 19 circumstances and
i'm not just talking about the left and
liberals let's let's not forget let's
not have a short memory yeah we know
when this pandemic hit you actually
tried to make me uh work out things with
sam harris i mean we had conservatives
people that were in the middle that were
saying no lockdowns now at least for now
at least for a couple of weeks yeah and
i was always like hell no hell no i know
what this is
it's paralyzing fear you're showing us
uniquely even the death count i mean how
bizarre for a news organization to say
stay at home and then every time
somebody dies just add a number on the
screen i mean that's literally a game of
psychological fear right and i knew it
was coming around the corner um and it
shocked me how much people left and
right were willing to give up their
freedom because they had a little bit of
fear right it shocked me i wasn't one of
them and i know that a lot of people
have come around on the conservative
side and said no more but how do we get
people to understand that we can't get
to the point where you say no more it
has to be never right in the beginning
when you're fearing fearful you can't
say well i was okay with the lockdowns
for two weeks but you know what one year
is a little too long for me right you've
already lost the game right as we're
about to roll into year three basically
right it was never okay and i think that
because i'm a bit more of a gut player
um and because i truly do understand how
sinister governments can be it's been
the story of human history since forever
i'm never willing to give up a little
bit of freedom for uh for a little bit
of safety well it's so funny to me
because since i know you privately and
as a friend i know that the stuff that
you talk about publicly even when i'm
like ah candace went a little overboard
on that one i'm like i know that is you
that really is you and we we told the
story once but the day that lockdown
started you were on my show in l.a we
didn't know at the time we were taping
that lockdowns were about to happen
right um you were caught literally
coughing up blood you were coughing up
but your your friend or your assistant
at the time was there also she was sick
yeah david's looking at me like we're
going to be trapped in the house for
months with candice he's going to die
here like it's all over but you were
like you were just like no i don't have
covet i'm fine like it has something to
do with the pillows at the hotel yeah
and and everyone's insane and i'm gonna
get the hell out of here yeah that was
so funny actually in retrospect like the
worst timing of me having an allergic
reaction to feathered pillows and like
your husband was not buying he's like no
no she's dying
but googling like to see like what was
happening but yeah you know and and that
was that was actually the last of an
idea before they sort of locked down
everything and all my events you know
necessarily got canceled but not because
of me i mean i attended everything um
you know i was pregnant during covert i
traveled the country i i traveled the
world i went to croatia um i went to
england i i just did not have this fear
i can't explain it it was just it was
too convenient um and it also obviously
didn't help their case that they had
predicted the coronavirus pandemic the
world economic forum a year prior you
know i think what we're dealing with
right now is a very sinister evil
globalist agenda um and that is not a
conspiracy i think that is a fact and uh
they want to exert control over every
single element of our lives and
unfortunately you have people that are
pliable to that control um because
they're fearful and also people that are
just lazy so one element is that people
are happy to be controlled because
they're fearful the other element is
because control is easy if you don't
have to think for yourself and somebody
just plugs you into a system and says do
this i mean
freedom is hard freedom is hard work
personal responsibility is hard growing
your own vegetables hey that's pretty
hard right it's kind of easy just go to
the grocery store and have it being
prepared people don't like to do things
that are difficult they want things to
be handed easily for them and that
that's why we have you know the
extraordinary welfare system that we
have why are you not afraid i know
you're not but everyone is basically
afraid seemingly but i i don't know is
it your wiring is it something you
learned very early on like why do you
always you see the thing in the distance
and you just go right to it for as many
times as twitter tried to take you out
or new york times or whoever it is you
just keep going and going and going yeah
you know i i get that question all the
time and the truth is that like i'm my
granddaddy's granddaughter i mean he
just was a tough guy he just passed in
september i obviously dedicated my book
to him uh my first book to him and you
know i have just always looked at my
life in comparison to his and it's the
reason why when people talk about their
oppression and i think of a man who grew
up in segregated south who never ever
ever um spoke about being oppressed
never spoke about why people were racist
never spoke about how the white man was
after him he just got up every day and
he worked and he did that from a time he
was five years old on a sharecropping
farm i find this generation of
individuals to be a little bit pathetic
i think we're a little bit pathetic i
think you know the greatest generation
that ever lived uh you know yielded the
most pathetic generation that's ever
lived which is which is we're walking
among walking among us today we just
can't do anything for ourselves and i
don't want i don't want to be that and
the other thing is i was just i'm just
wired this way i was like this since i
was a little girl
my parents always tell stories about me
like i was just one of those precocious
kids that just never allowed an adult to
tell me what to do without reason um i
never responded to arbitrary authority
like i was one of those kids that if
your parents were like well you know
clean your bed or santa's not gonna come
i would say like you tell him not to
come right
um and so they were always laughing and
having to close the door to reprimand me
because i was kind of like this little
adult and i think in
my character is really just that i'm i i
respect authority um but the authority
can't be arbitrary it needs to make
sense and if it doesn't make sense
you're just you're and you're okay with
it then you know that sets up the
grounds for slavery and i'm not a slave
you are not a slave that is for sure uh
but will you be a politician will i be a
politician um i get this question all
the time and i used to say no and now i
i say never say never um you know i've
had those conversations with my husband
before about what it would actually
mean um
and i definitely would never be in
congress i can tell you absolutely not
i've done two of those hearings i would
rather honestly pull out all of my
fingernails that was one of your best
moments the one with you and ted lou was
like
really incredible and then remember we
had that event i forget i don't even
remember where we were that night but
like you left that event you destroyed
everyone there yeah and then you just go
on with your life yeah i mean these
people are just are are real losers
setting up all these hearings but
are you nervous in any of those things
like i do this for a living too and i
don't really get nervous but i haven't
sat in front of congress yes
and just destroyed them let me tell you
something congress works for you not the
other way around i actually think that
the way that that whole little
auditorium is set up is wrong why are
they above me yeah i should be literally
there yeah they're literally above you
and i believe that we should literally
be above them i don't even like the way
it's set up and this is the idea we've
gotten this idea that they're above us
they're not they literally work for us
and and and the majority of them on on
the democrat side are a bunch of
scumbags and they're working to destroy
this country they've sold us out um a
lot of them or have been in dc forever
are just corrupt and trying to fill
their own pockets so i had no fear i was
angry um at the obvious setup and the
attempt to play me um and i was happy
that i was able to expose them for what
they were but i don't have fear you know
of people that are essentially my
employees do you
have anyone that you've been trying to
talk to to get into a debate with that
has refused them there's got to be some
but you've you've done you've done a
couple of these like with russell brand
who you had major differences with and a
couple other people i find it very hard
to get these people to talk at this
point because we have racist homophobic
tickets
um is there anyone like that's like on
your list that you feel like if you
could just get them to break maybe it
would it would do something really big
you know
not anymore because obviously there's
just been this
long frustration with realizing that
they love to talk about you to garner
clicks but when you say hey show up if
you're about it show up they always say
no i mean i think even last week we
invited anna kasparian i think she's
dedicated hours and hours
hours of coverage
of me and i have dedicated literally
zero seconds of coverage to her and i
said okay let's have her on the show and
have a civil conversation and and she
declined so
um i russell brand is an amazing human
being he really is and he's saying stuff
the reason why he was willing to host me
and he's willing to host others is
because he genuinely believed what he
was saying right if you genuinely
believe what you were saying even if
it's wrong but you believe it to be true
i can deal with that right and we can
talk we can have a conversation because
we both want to become better and we
both want to discover the truth if you
know what you are saying is a lie and
you tell about lie day in and day out
you have to hide right because you can't
face yourself and you can't face the
truth um so i always think that that
that kind of marks the difference in the
personalities that we see on the left
and there's not too many of them that
are willing to sit down with people on
the right has some of that sort of
translated to how you do your show
because you're doing something that i'm
trying to do as well which is not make
people crazy i'm really not i'm actually
trying to do the reverse i want people
if they watch by the end to be like i
laughed a couple times like oh i thought
about this but i'm not like insane and
almost everyone now that's in our space
is almost designed to make everybody
crazy it's actually funny you say that
because i would say about five episodes
ago maybe a few more i kind of sit down
with the team and i said let's make this
show more positive right because the
feeling that i was getting of even
reporting on some of this stuff was it
was just getting so depressing and so
overwhelming and i was like there's a
way to still tell people what's going on
without people walking away feeling like
you know we're going to lose this
country and the truth is that i'm
hopeful and i'm optimistic or i wouldn't
get up in the morning but i genuinely
thought that we had no shot at winning
what would be my incentive for getting
up in the morning and doing this and
producing the show and the same for you
right what would be your incentive um
and and i know i mentioned this to you
uh last night but you know there's also
this element of realizing that the
reason why they have been so obviously
corrupt right it's never been more in
your face hey we're just gonna teach
your kids pornography right parents or
domestic terrorists this is like wild
this is not even a good strategy for the
left to do this right well they're
losing control and when barack obama was
president they didn't need to censor
they didn't need to kick people off of
platforms didn't any of that because
they actually owned the narrative they
were winning in 2008 the democrat party
was legitimately winning right they
didn't need to say mail in ballots
forever or anything weird because they
were legitimately winning and we were
all asleep me being among them you being
among them completely asleep at the
wheel well now things have changed um
and because of that change because they
feel like they're losing grip they're
becoming more desperate so i tell people
to remain optimistic and inspired by
their desperation
what do you think their move is as they
get more desperate because they can't
let this go on for too long right this
is what we were talking about last night
it's like if if enough of us are awake
and if we're waking up people and
they're seeing the truth and they can
watch the written house trial see how
msnbc reports it versus what's actually
going on it's like they can't the powers
that be can't let that exist for too
long because then they have a much
bigger problem on their hands well you
see their play i mean you see brian
stelter you have journalists that are
calling for censorship yeah boggles my
mind right some fourth estate right
they're literally saying to you we're
not the fourth state we we are we are
part of the government we're part of
corporate media our job is to protect
the government not to protect the
individuals that are being governed um
and and you're seeing them call for more
and more attention they're angry they're
frustrated by the fact that you know
they spend all day working on their show
maybe they get 100 000 viewers like it's
in a tweet that will get more views that
they don't know what to do with that
yeah um and so in their frustration
they're demanding more censorship but
it's like you just can't keep you can't
censor people until there's no more um i
think what's coming up around the corner
and something that i i've been telling
people to pay attention to
is that the world economic forum the
same people that predicted the
chronovirus pandemic are now predicting
a cyber pandemic uh where they predict
um that because of the internet and
things like bitcoin being uncontrolled
um that they're going to have to
physically shut down the power grid
because there's going to be a virus
literally like think of like chronovirus
for your computer is what they actually
said in this um forum um that is going
to spread you know very quickly so
they're going to shut down the power
grid to stop it and you know for a
couple of days whatever it is you're not
going to have access to your money or
access to the internet and then when
they turn things back on in order to
avoid a shutdown like that again they're
going to need to sanitize the internet
this is actually language at the world
economic forum is using sitting down
with the biggest corporations in the
world uh talking about what they are
describing as an inevitable coronavirus
pandemic for your computer that's the
stuff to pay attention to because that
would allow them to similarly in the
copa 19 pandemic usher in a bunch of
things that we've never seen before
that i think would provide a venue for
them to take control over the internet
to take out people like me and like you
um to say that we had to sanitize the
internet to keep everybody safe um so i
always tell people to kind of look
around the bed hope it doesn't happen uh
but always be aware of any types of
simulation uh you know the world
economic forum is running and then at
that point of two days even even eight
hours where we couldn't get online you
wouldn't have access to twitter or your
bank account or whatever people would
beg
for the control at that point right yeah
i mean imagine new york city right so
imagine maybe in tennessee they'd be
like all right we're gonna go uh we're
gonna go hunting oh it's so great oh
internet right this is great and amazing
you'll be all right george's cigar room
right exactly but imagine a place like
tennessee which i mean a place like new
york city or los angeles these people
live eat and breathe technology there is
nothing without technology in new york
city it's literally just it looks like a
piece of technology when you look at it
from the sky right and so imagine those
people not having access the whole power
grid going down let's say they do it for
four days right
and they would be beside themselves they
wouldn't know what to do these people
don't i don't even know what they would
be eating what would happen in the
grocery stores they can't keep
refrigerators on i mean it would really
represent something that would
traumatize these people rightfully so it
would be traumatizing for them to go
through their livelihood would be
immediately impacted and when that power
grid went back on the government said
like you know now you have access to
your money everything's back but here's
what we have to do to make sure that
four days never happens again yeah they
will be the first in line right just
like they were the first in line for the
vaccine cards don't let us go into
restaurants because they will be so
paralyzed by fear these individuals will
then be begging the government for more
censorship begging the government to
sanitize the internet begging saying
whatever you have whatever freedoms you
have to take away from me take it i just
want to make sure that that never
happens again back to our thesis here
about fear and and how that as a driver
is the biggest threat to humanity and
freedom for humanity all right so we
only got a couple minutes left because
because you got a show and i'm gonna do
your show very exciting there's all
these people here we should do another
show uh so in like three minutes or so
what else is kind of on your mind or
maybe just like more what give me like
candace the candice that i know not the
candice yeah everybody else knows yeah
uh you know i think for me the next few
years
um every day really is about family for
me like you know i don't think people
really get to see the personal side of
me because you can't let them in
politics you know they're just evil
um but i i try to just tell everybody
that family is the most important thing
every single day and i try to if i can
prescribe anything um upon the world it
would be read the bible uh not because
you need to be religious but because it
has good values you know what i mean
read the bible as if as as you would
read aesop's fables right there's just
good moralities and lessons in there and
um i definitely am someone that like
i'll just puruse and read things and and
you go through the scriptures and you
realize that you know you walk away with
an understanding that evil is evil and
it can always get more evil but in the
end goodness wins um and i think that we
have to understand that nothing is going
to change until we take care of our
households first maybe this is the
jordan peterson make your bed right um
so
invest that time when the world seems
evil invest that time in making your
home a better place and and making good
personal individual decisions and i
think that enough of us do that and and
we save this place
i got to tell you candace it's weird
because we do this publicly and
privately so there's this like odd lens
around it sort of in a public sense but
i am just so truly i'm so proud of you
it's like that's what i feel when i'm
with you like i feel like
you're doing something real and so many
people that i've come across in this
it's not real it's fake or it's so true
infused or it's muddled or something and
and you're the real deal and it's very
cool that uh that i'm part of the still
the same person right can you give me
credit and you love chicken parm that's
something people don't know about you
you love a good chicken oh chicken
that's why i want chickens actually my
husband says i can't have them in this
house but we'll see i know how the game
works with wives we wear them down in
the end i will have those chickens if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell